es ist der hammer hier in köln er bricht
gerade der frühling aus die leute kommen
aus ihren löchern und auch zur klick zum
kommt die man zwar glasperlenspiel sie
stehen ja für den wettbewerb 361 grad
respekt auf youtube wo ihr eure videos
zum thema gegen mobbing und für toleranz
einreichen können und erster preis ist
ein konzert mit der band für euch und
eure freunde und zweiter preis ist
backstage bei einem klick zum interview
dabei zu sein jetzt könnte aber schon
mitmachen bei klink sowie eure frage an
das planspiel stellt als kommentar hier
unter dem video oder als video frage die
er als video antwort dann postet und
umso kreativer ihr seid profis wissen
dass umso höher sind die chancen dass
ihr dran kommen also bis dann bleibt
dran